STEVE: THE REVOLT IN CANADA IS
NOT JUST A POWERFUL RESPONSE
TO THE COOL DESTRUCTIVE
MADNESS OF CORONA LAW BUT IT
IS A SIGNAL OF A HISTORIC
POLITICAL REALIGNMENT THE KIND
THAT ONLY HAPPENS ONCE OR
TWICE A CENTURY.
STARTED WITH TRUMP WHO
REFOCUSED THE REPUBLICAN PARTY
ON THE WORKING CLASS AND MADE
HE WAS FOUR.
>> PRO WORKER, PRO- WORKERS.
>> PRO WORKER.
THE FORGOTTEN MEN AND WOMEN OF
OUR COUNTRY WILL BE FORGOTTEN
NO LONGER.
STEVE: TRUMP HAD PRO WORKER
POLICIES PRO WORKER TAX CUTS
AND REGULATORY REFORM AND PRO
WORKER TRADE DEALS AND
INITIATIVES ON SKILLS AND
TRAINING.
ALL OF THIS PRODUCE THE BEST
RESULTS FOR AMERICAN WORKERS
IN AT LEAST HALF A CENTURY AND
THE DEMOCRATS FOR DECADES
THOUGHT THEY WERE THE WORKERS
PARTY.
BUT AS THE ELITIST WOKE
ACTIVISTS CLASS TOOK OVER THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY, THEY ADOPTED
THE ANTIWORKER POLICY AGENDA.
STRONG ENERGY JOBS WITH
EXTREMIST ZEALOTRY DESTROYING
BLUE-COLLAR EARNINGS WITH
MIGRATION AND THE LIVING
STANDARDS WITH LOWER INFLATION
THEY TRIED TO CLAIM THEY WERE
FOR THE WORKERS.
>> EVERY SENATOR FROM EVERY
STATE HAS WITNESSED OUT THE
HOLLOWING OF THE MIDDLE CLASS
THE LAST DECADES.
>> THAT NOW THE MASK IS OFF
DEMOCRATS AND THEIR STOOGES
AND THE MEDIA HAVE STOPPED
PRETENDING.
THEY HATE WORKERS.
THEY REALLY DO THINK WORKERS
ARE THE DEPLORABLE'S RACIST
CONSPIRACY THEORIST.
>> IT ISN'T JUST TRUCKERS THAT
Q-ANON SUPPORTERS IN THE
CROWD.
>> IT'S MUCH MORE COMPLICATED
THAN JUST A SMALL GROUP OF
PEOPLE WHO ARE FRUSTRATED
ABOUT VACCINE MANDATES NOT
WHEN YOU ARE WAVING NAZI FLAGS
AND CONFEDERATE FLAGS TO HAVE
FAR RIGHT EXTREMIST MARCHING
IN THE STREETS AND THREATENING
LOCAL RESIDENTS.
>> IT IS A COLD.
>> HELL YES.
>> DEMOCRATS WANT TO CRUSH THE
WORKERS FIRST PLACE OF THE
STAGE IT SHARES IN AFFINITY
WITH THE TOXIC AUTHORITARIAN.
POLITICS.
>> THEY ARE INCITING AND
ENCOURAGING PEOPLE TO BREAK
THE LAW AND TO DO SO IN A WAY
THAT DEVASTATES SO MANY
HARD-WORKING PEOPLE.
STEVE: THEN THE WORKERS MUST
BE CRASHED.
THIS IS WHERE CNN ARREST THE
CASTINGS THEN MOVE THE TRACKS
THESE ELITISTS ARE WAGING THE
CLASS WAR FROM ABOVE LOOK DOWN
THEIR NOSES AT BLUE-COLLAR
WORKERS THE ONLY REASON THEY
ARE ABLE TO LOUNGE AROUND AND
THEIR MOVING THEM IN YOGA
PANTS IS BECAUSE BLUE-COLLAR
WORKERS KEPT THEIR POWER ON
AND THEIR OWN MILK AND VEGAN
SAUSAGES DELIVERED.
EVEN WORSE THAN THAT
CONVERSATION ON -┘- BUT THE
FAVORITE NEW INSULT ESSENTIAL
ON -┘- INSURRECTION.
>> WHEN THE POLICE CHIEF SAYS
IT IS A NATIONWIDE
INSURRECTION DRIVEN BY
MADNESS.
>> INC. OF THE LANGUAGE IT
SOUNDS FAMILIAR A THREAT TO
DEMOCRACY.
THE INSURRECTION, SEDITION.
>> ORGANIZERS OF THE PROTEST
STARTED MORE THAN A WEEK AGO
WANTED TO OVERTHROW THE
GOVERNMENT.
>> YOU HAVE AN INSURRECTION
UNDERWAY IN THE CAPITAL OF A
VERY IMPORTANT COUNTRY.
STEVE: WHEN YOU TRY TO CRUSH
DEFENSE BY FALSELY BRANDING A
POLITICAL PROTEST AS AN
INSURRECTION, THAT IS THE
DEFINITION OF AUTHORITARIANISM
OR FASCISM.
TO THE DEMOCRATS AND CNN TO
REALIZE HOW RECKLESS AND ANTI-
AMERICAN IT IS.
WE HAVE TO STAND UP TO THE
TACTICS THEY DON'T CALLED IN
THE INSURRECTION IS BECAUSE
THEY ACTUALLY THINK THEY WENT
TO OVERTHROW THE GOVERNMENT
BUT THEY DO IT BECAUSE THEY
CANNOT STAND ANY CHALLENGE TO
THEIR IDEOLOGY WE KNOW BEST
TECHNOCRATIC ZEALOTRY THEY
TRIED TO INTIMIDATE PEOPLE
FROM CHALLENGING PEOPLE AND WE
MUST NOT ALLOW THEM TO SUCCEED
A KEY PART OF THAT ESTATE ON
THE HIGH GROUND THAT'S WHY IT
DESCRIBE THE CAPITAL RIOT AS A
LEGITIMATE POLITICAL DISCOURSE
KNOW IT WAS A RIOT THAT IS NOT
LEGITIMATE POLITICAL DISCORD
NOT LAND ANTIFA DOES IT OR
TRUMP SUPPORTERS DO IT EITHER.
THE REPUBLICAN PARTY HAS A
MASSIVE OPPORTUNITY TO NOT
SCREW IT UP.
AS WE SAW IN THE 2020 ELECTION
THE GOP IS BECOMING A
MULTIRACIAL WORKING-CLASS
COALITION.
THAT IS SOMETHING WE HAVE LONG
ARGUED FOR HERE.
GIVES REPUBLICANS A POLITICAL
ADVANTAGE FOR GENERATIONS WITH
MORE WORKING AMERICANS AND
WORK FROM HOME ELITIST.
WE STAYED AT THE TOP OF THE
SHOW EVERY SUNDAY.
PROUDLY PRO WORKER AND PRO
AMERICA.
LET'S MAKE SURE WE PURSUE
THOSE THEMES POSITIVELY AND ON
THE BASIS OF CLEAR AND
CONSISTENT PRINCIPL